I know you have a son and I think Hubble
he's done nine years old nine next week
not next week okay and how's he doing
he's are awesome having a kid is awesome
having a little boy is awesome he's Mike
my mini nerd we're loving the Avengers
all this stuff and but he's nude all the
time it's an issue nude yeah he just you
know is that age they're naked I'm naked
he comes home from school and it's just
nudity and I'm like oh god and the only
reason he even wears clothes is it's
required by law when you bring your
child to California Pizza Kitchen but
you cover their in balls you know if
that view could be nub out at the cpk he
would yeah I get it who doesn't want eat
pizza with your wiener out no I face
it's a club we all wish to belong to so
what he's a problem so I'm in my office
listening to it this happened recently
I'm listening some Ozzy Osbourne by
myself I enjoy the Ozzy third solo
record bark at the moon title track it's
about werewolves werewolves are super
kick-ass right sure yeah so it's all
going well yeah my son also enjoys yeah
my son also enjoys Ozzy Osbourne cuz
I've raised him right
and I don't know if he was on the other
side of the house fully nude heard Ozzy
and came running in or if he was on the
other side of the house fully clothed
heard Ozzy got nude because all I know
is my side of the story I was listening
to some Ozzy guitar so it was about to
start one of my favorite guitar players
from the mid-80s Jay Keely about to rip
something and my son on cue pops into
the doorway naked and goes daddy wiener
solo wiener solo and then ripped it like
a prodigy but yeah whammy bar action oh
wow I've never been more proud of my
[Applause]
life like I had a tear - smile yeah like
see the Millennium Falcon again in force
awakens you are you're teaching him and
I believe you are I are you teaching him
good values on him Charles that's right
when you get busted sometimes but we try
so my wife and I love Disneyland and
sometimes we like to go without him I
know it sounds terrible he's little in
there certain rides he doesn't like yet
so we like to go on the honey man see
and we like to go on a Space Mountain
and all that it's too intense for him so
we went alone just the two of us and
then we were taking pictures all day to
post on Facebook of us like in front
arrives like we're in Star Tours going
Shh like don't tell him we're cheating
on him right you know and then we don't
post it but a couple weeks later my wife
is driving and we're in trap but she's
in traffic with him and he's in the back
and he says hey mom can I look at your
phone I'm bored and she hands on the
phone and he looks at the phone and goes
hey mom when did you and dad find the
chance to go to Disneyland without me
and she goes oh that was a long time ago
and he goes October 24th was two weeks
ago I'm freaking out she tells me and
I'm like aw man we're busted and like
thank God he didn't look at my phone I
was like way worse then he tells my mom
he tells my mom that we went to
Disneyland without him and then he comes
to me and goes hey why did you go to
Disneyland without me and I'm thinking
in my head like oh this is a big lesson
here I can tell him that yes even
grown-ups we have to be honest and we
you know we can't lie and we shouldn't
do that you know that kind of thing this
is a big lesson instead I just said you
know snitches don't get to go to
Disneyland dude
[Applause]
that's the motto
you